me
ん
[音楽]
me
[拍手]
あなたは3分でつくることができるカップラーメンを1分で作れと言われたら何を
考えるでしょうか
そんなの無理だ諦めようと思うのでしょうか
それとも何とか知恵を振り絞って1分で完成させようと考えるでしょうか
僕たちラグビー部は
週3回
1回の練習は最大90分
ネタ休みは1週間のが式のみの練習しかありません
つまり僕たちの練習時間は
カップラーメンを1分で作れと言われているのと同じ状況なのです
しかし僕たちはこれまで
小園静岡県チャンピオンになり全国大会に出場しました
なぜ僕たちがそんなことを成し遂げることができたのか
そのカギは2つあります
以下にその1分間を工夫して効率的に行動するかと
残りの2分をどのように使うかです
今日は部活動を通じて僕たちが学んだ
今自分たちが浮かれた環境についての考え方をみなさんにお伝えしたいと思います
部活動の練習は週3日
1回は最大90分であるというのは
ぶんぶりょうどうを目指すために学校創立当初からラグビー部だけでなく全ての部活動
共通で決められたことです
しかしそこには僕たちにとってさまざまな不都合があります
それでも僕たちはこの1分間の中でなんとか
おいしいカップラーメンを食べたい
だから僕たちはこの1分間を工夫して
僕たちはこの1分間を大切にし工夫することでより中身の声ものにしています
この取り組みの中から代表的な実践例とその狙いをお話します
全国的な部活動の練習時間と比べると僕たちの練習時間は短いです
そこで先ほどの
1分間で作り上げるというカップラーメンの原理を使えます
僕たちは練習時間中に練習メニューの内容を確認する時間が確保できません
ですから火曜木曜土曜日の朝にラグビー部員のみでミーティングを行い
ここでその日の練習メニューを発表します
あらかじめ練習メニューを発表しておくことで善意がその練習メニューにおいて意識
するべきポイントを認識した状態で練習に入ることができます
そして僕たち部員みんなが集まる貴重な時間を
一人でもできる坂ダッシュ
走り込みなど体力づくりをする時間に使ってしまってはもったいないと考え練習中に
走り込みやしません
その代わりに1回の練習で約10回ある給水の時間をダッシュの時間として有効活用し
ています
こちらがその映像です
入れる
[音楽]
さらに僕たちラグビー部ではラグビーに対する意識や知識にまだまだギャップがあり
ます
ラグビーに対する意識がバラバラではシアはおろか
短い練習でさえも成り立ちません
そこで
医師と5ミーティングというビデオミーティングを行い
練習中確認したいプレーを映像で分かりやすく
全員が同じイメージを持つことができるようにします
また次の対戦相手の分析も合わせてより効率的な練習ができるようにします
練習時間が短いのにその大切な時間を
ビデオに使うのか
と思われるかもしれませんがなんとなくの90分のトレーニングか
意思統一ができた80分のトレーニングかをスローガンになんとなくこなしてしまう
練習より
全員が同じイメージを描きる練習のほうがずっと効率的だと考えました
またタコはなら練習時間中に
納得するまでとことん話し合って問題を解決できる
話し合いの時間さえも僕達にありません
そこで水分補給の時間をプレイの振り返り
話や時間にしました
ここで重要なのが絶対活動とか気合い入れて行くぞという
ティア売れる話し合いにしないことです
そうではなく具体的に次にどんなプレイをすべきなのかという話し合いにします
この話会をよりよくするために
good but next の3ポイントを明確にまとめ
みんなの意識を一つにします
ラグビーの試合中も捉えのあと約1分間の話は時間があります
僕たちは練習から試合を想定して1分間で話し合うことを意識しています
この話し合いでポイントを明確にすることで次にチーム全員が意識することを一つに
することができます
ここまで短い練習時間をどう使うかについてお話ししてきました
ところが今話してきたのはほかの人が3分でつくるカップラーメンを1分間に一生懸命
両宿して作り上げる作業です
これでは時間が短縮されただけで結局3分でできたものと1分で完成したカップ
ラーメン自体に何の変わりもありません
ところが僕たちはカップラーメンを1分で作り上げることの裏に
2分間も自由な時間ができたことに気がつきました
この時間をどう使うかは自分次第
ただぼーっとしているだけでもいいし考えて何か行動を起こすのもいい
そこで僕たちはただボーっと過ごしてしまうのはもったいない
そう思いこの時間で新たな一歩を踏み出し
カップラーメンをさらに良いものにしていくことを選びました
最も大切なのはこの時間をどう使っていくことなのかです
僕たちはこの時間を主体的に行動することを意識しています
主体性と似ている言葉に実勢というものがあります
違いがよくわからないかもしれません
しかしこれらは似ているようで全く違うものなです
実勢とは決められた課題を自ら率先して行動することであり
主体性とは何をすべきか決められていないことを自ら考えて行動することです
勉強例にとります家に帰って親から何も言われることなく
自分から取り掛かる宿題が実勢
家に帰り宿題を早く終わらせ余った時間で
この前の英語のテストで英単語の意味がわからず
長文読解ができなかったからこの時間で英単語を勉強しようと思い
宿題プラスアルファの勉強するのが主体性です
この主体性が発揮される場面は主に2つ
通常の学校生活と長期間中です
通常の学校生活では朝の修行前と放課後は自由に使えます
そこで僕たちは委員会活動や各教科の先生が開いてくれる
補修に参加することができます
受験が近くなった高校3年生の部員は特にこの補修に参加する傾向があります
またこの時間の他の使い方としてもちろん給与をすることもあります
僕たちはそれを良くないこととは捉えておりません
休むことで q 8時間を十分に確保し費用
回復することができます
部員たちは良いコンディションを維持することができるのでより多くのことに
チャレンジをすることが可能です
また長期間中も自分で友好的に時間の使うことができる期間です
僕たちはここで成し遂げシートというものを使って自分たちのセルフマネジメントに
磨きをかけています
成し遂げシートでは1日ごとの吹き樹や1日の過ごし方を表にまとめます
こうすることで自分の行動計画が可視化されより無駄のない効率的な1日が過ごせます
そんな夏休みを過ごす部員もやることは様々です
留学に行くことができたり学校で行われる
夏期補習に参加することもできます
僕はこの長期間を利用して
3つの国に留学しました
各々が苦手克服のために取り組む夏休みは僕たちにとってとても重要な時間です
しかしこの期間中に体を動かさないわけにもいきません
合宿を最高のコンディションで臨むためにはこの時間でトレーニングをすることが
不可欠です
あのプレーが2月がこんなプレーがしたいと思ったら
自分に今何が足りないのかを考えそのための練習を行うなど
この時間を有意義に使えます
人が得意とすること
苦手なことを優先して取り組みたいことなどは人それぞれです
またたとえ同じ人でもその時の状況によって
優先順位は違うはず
自分についてよく理解し苦手を潰していけるこの時間をただなんとなく過ごすのでは
なく全力で過ごしたらなんて有意義な時間になるのでしょう
週3日
1回は最大90分
夏休みは1週間の合宿しか練習がないという環境で
全国大会に出場するのは不可能だ
この環境ではできない仕方がないと思うのはあんたんです
こんなことを思うと気持ちが楽になるかもしれません
しかし気持ちが楽になっただけそれも一瞬のことで実際は何も変わっていないのです
自分たちにできることを考えに考え悩みに悩んで
工夫していくことにチャレンジしなければ何も変わらないのです
成し遂げる
これは僕たちラグビー部の物件です
たとえ90パーセントの力を出したとしても満足してしまっては成し遂げたことには
なりません
与えられた環境を100%活用することが重要なのです
僕たちラグビー部にもまだまだ空すべきところや工夫できるところはたくさんあります
皆さんもさまざまな環境に置かれていると思います
自分にとって都合の悪い環境
周りと比べて圧倒的に不利な状況
でもどんな環境でも何かできることがあるのではないでしょうか
工夫できることがあるのではないでしょうか
考え自分が変わることで3分かかるカップラーメンも1分でできるはず
そうしたら2分間も自由な時間ができます
この時間を主体的に行動すれば不利な状況なんて関係ありません
自分たちが置かれた環境を最大限活用し周りから不可能だと思われていることを
成し遂げて新たな未来を切り開きましょう
[拍手]